researcher Martin pushed the deck
against the door hoping it would hold
long enough for him to find an alternate
Escape Route he wasn't thinking about
the long term he couldn't afford to with
the foundation's global reach he'd never
truly Escape them never be able to make
it away condemned to spend the rest of
his life on the run from the
organization he devoted his life to it
was too overwhelming to even attempt to
reckon with that especially with the
pounding of a fist against the door he
scrabbled around opening Windows to try
and see if there was a safe way down
technically none of this was his fault
at least in his mind the administrative
login information he'd used to access
the file shouldn't have been left so
easy to find that was just poor cyber
security on the foundation's part
researcher Martin had been tasked with
compiling information on scp-001 one of
the most infamous anomalies ever
encountered in the foundation's long and
storied history or multi
what Martin had come to learn was there
were numerous entities within the
foundation's files that all acted as
proposals for scp-001 some were
creatures the typical kind of anomalous
entities the foundation dealt with on a
regular basis but some of the proposals
focused on more abstract anomalies and
somehow those were more existentially
terrifying than any evil Godlike being
bent on destroying reality theories
about the very source of anomalies
themselves but their very existence
might have been predetermined by some
otherworldly Force then there were the
other proposals that name parts of the
foundation as the true
scp-001 those seem to suck researcher
mountain in like a Vortex dragging him
down a deep dark rabbit hole that made
him start to question everything he
thought he knew about working for the
SCP Foundation and the one that had
toppled him into a full-blown conspiracy
obsessed stupor that there was no coming
back from the Noir box proposal the
weighted head of a battering ram
splintered the wooden surface of the
door spraying fragments over the room
the table propped up to keep it shut
toppled under the force of the entry as
a squad of shadowy figures in full black
combat gear rushed inside the mobile
task force surrounded the cowering
researcher keeping their weapons trained
on him researcher Martin pleading for
his life started gesturing to the walls
of the room around him that had been
plastered with hastily scrawled diagrams
and equations Martin tried desperately
to find some concise easy to understand
way of explaining to the soldiers what
he'd uncovered they only picked up on a
few words like many worlds hypothesis
and splitting universes But ultimately
they didn't follow what he was saying
and weren't sent there to hear him out
all the MTF had been told was that
researcher Martin had breached
Foundation security and now posed a risk
of exposing sensitive information about
scp-001 there was only one pass of
recourse termination however unbeknownst
to them Dr Martin was fine at least a
version of him was one who never learned
about the Noir box proposal for scp-001
and hadn't gone mad trying to unravel
its Mysteries instead he was a respected
higher ranking member of the foundation
who was alive and well in a completely
different timeline the formation of the
SCP Foundation has always been shrouded
in mystery with nobody really knowing
what the true origin of the organization
is and what is merely just a cover story
left in the archives to keep the truth
hidden
scp-001 the Noir box proposal at least
might hold the answers to the questions
surrounding how the foundation came to
be three times over known as the
tindelos Trinity the file pertaining to
this anomaly is buried deep in the SCP
foundation's database under layers upon
layers of encryption and security
clearance requirements it require
someone at the very top level of the
foundation to access a member of either
the overseer Council or the foundation's
high command or OverWatch but wait what
are those aren't they the same thing
well yes and no the exact name of the
high-ranking secretive group that runs
the foundation has often been
interchangeable whether they're known as
the o5 council the overseer Council Etc
but what if it wasn't just many
different names for the same governing
body but actually separate names for
alternate versions of the ones who
control the SCP Foundation allow us to
explain all three of these groups the
overseer Council High command and
OverWatch have come to a consensus that
scp-001 is an anomaly that connects with
the foundation's very origin they
believe that the founder of the SCP
Foundation also known as scp-001 was
anomalous in some way that caused them
to interact with time in an usual
fashion the triumviron of councils are
in agreement that around the time that
the SCP Foundation was formed three
distinct timelines were generated given
the anomalous nature of the
organization's founder each of these
timelines drastically altered the nature
of scp-001 featuring a different version
in each one in the first commonly known
as timeline HC where the foundation is
run by a high command
scp-001 was an anomalous human corpse
this timeline's scp-001 still exhibited
all the behavioral characteristics of a
normal human being but could
additionally replicate itself at an
erratic uncontrollable rate usually when
performing tasks that could have
multiple possible outcomes
scp-001 and timeline HC also interacted
anachronistically with its environment
passing through solid matter that
predated it or would Outlast it so it
had to be contained in a room that was
constructed before it existed as an
anomaly this timelines scp-001 was
responsible for conceiving the idea for
the SCP Foundation and was able to
promote a significant interest in the
organization however they were
assassinated before the foundation was
officially codified with the culprits
being a version of mobile task force Alp
zero were believed to have originated
from either of the other two timelines
while this seems to have been done to
deter the foundation forming in this
timeline it seems to have had the
opposite effect despite the
assassination of scp-001 occurring
before the official formation of the SCP
Foundation in Timeline HC this version
of the foundation was successfully
codified by the 13 members of what they
referred to as high command given the
anomalous circumstances around the death
of scp-001 it provided the Catalyst for
the organization to immediately
establish itself as this timeline's
protection against the threat posed by
anomalous entities the body of SC cp001
was placed in the building that had been
its childhood home securing it somewhere
that predated them to negate their
anomalous properties this made them the
first anomaly contained by timeline hc's
version of the SCP Foundation
posthumously garnering them the official
designation of
scp-001 so that's the first of our three
timelines at play the events that unfold
in the second are considerably different
in this timeline timeline OC the
foundation was initially created by a
different
scp-001 this entity referred to
primarily as the founder appropriately
enough was a human being known to
possess anomalous temporal abilities the
founder was known to also be immortal
showing no visible signs of aging and
with a resistance to external damage
that prevented him from being directly
killed any injuries he sustained could
be healed but only at the same rate
typical of an average human being the
temporal side of his anomalous property
pertain to predicting the future the
founder was able to with an inaugurable
level of precision and accuracy forecast
events before they occurred his
foresight had appeared to the foundation
was not inciting these events to happen
as he predicted them however everything
he ever predicted would occur became an
inevitability impossible to delay avert
or alter through any means during the
events of timeline OC and as his
preferred nickname implies the founder
was the soul figure responsible for
establishing this version of the SCP
Foundation in this course of events the
o5 Council of this timeline were known
as the overseer Council it was however
while he was in the process of
establishing the organization that
things started to go awry whether he was
able to predict this occurrence or not
is unknown although it seems to have
corresponded with the MTF Alp zero
assassination of scp-001 in the other
timeline timeline HC in Timeline OC at
the same time as the assassination in
Timeline HC the founder began to exhibit
his anomalous temporal properties in
front of the original members of
overseer Council however it should also
be noted that there was no recorded
presence of MTF Alp zero in Timeline OC
believing the founder to be a potential
danger to the foundation they had all
helped to create the founding overseer
Council classified him as an anomalous
threat they immediately devised a set of
containment measures for the founder now
designating him as scp-001 the first
anomaly contained by this timeline's
version of the foundation he was placed
within a standard humanoid containment
cell and given regular meals while
Personnel were forbidden to communicate
with them given his role in establishing
the foundation in this version of events
scp-001 is naturally in favor of
containing and analyzing anomalies
however not when that includes him and
insisted that he being released
according to one of his predictions for
forthcoming events he requested to be
allowed to build a device but refused to
elaborate on the intended purpose of it
scp-001 even refused to allow other
members of foundation Personnel to
construct the device on his behalf for
testing purposes the third of these
timelines is referred to as timeline ow
wherein the leading body of the
foundation are known as OverWatch here
just like the previous iterations of its
history the description of scp-001 and
their role in forming the SCP Foundation
differs in this timeline
scp-001 is an anomaly that consists of
two distinct Parts the first of these is
a figured not dissimilar from the
founder referred to as
scp-001-1 this person is also a
functionally Immortal human who doesn't
age and can't heal rapidly from damage
scp-001-1 also advocates for securing
and analyzing anomalies however this
includes himself as he doesn't object to
his own containment or that of the
second component of this as cp001 known
as
scp-001-a this device is capable of
accurately calculating any and all
possible outcomes of any event that is
input into it unlike the founder who
seemed to possess a foresight able to
predict the only inevitable outcome of
the future
scp-001-a is able to account for the
possibility of multiple potential
Futures even down to accounting for how
its own predictions could potentially
influence or alter outcomes in layman's
terms at least one of the eventualities
predicted by
scp-001-a will always be accurate unless
the predictions are to do with its own
future or the future of
scp-001-1 in this instance the device
will always produce one of two
assumptions that are incorrect either
that scp-001-1 was killed after an
assassination attempt and never
constructed as
cp001-a but that's impossible after all
as CPS those are 1-8 exists it's already
been made in this timeline the other
incorrect prediction it can give is that
scp-001-1 also exhibits the same
anomalous properties as the prediction
machine more akin to the founder and
that
scp-001-a was never constructed in the
first place but again that can't be
right in this timeline anyway according
to records within timeline ow their
version of the founder who is of course
as cp001-1 encountered a version of
mobile task force Alp Zero from one of
the other timelines they presented the
founder of the ow timeline with detailed
blueprints for the construction of
scp-001-a the device's completion
coincided with the assassination in
Timeline HC and the corresponding
anomalous incident in Timeline OC after
this point MTF Alp zero departs from
timeline ow this version of the SCP
Foundation is then created to study the
device SCP
001-8 with this founder and a group of
his close friends who would become this
foundation's OverWatch following this
initial research group's discovery of
other anomalous phenomenon that
threatened the rest of society the
team's goal expanded to research
anomalies and protect the world from the
danger they posed however the rest of
the OverWatch began to age at a natural
range while the founder didn't recognize
this he volunteered to be contained and
studied thus becoming a component of
this timeline's
scp-001 stepping back and looking at all
these timelines there seems to be a
number of marked similarities
particularly relating to how the
foundation was established and how a
figure usually the one who founded the
organization possessed anomalous means
of interacting with time and temporality
under normal circumstances interaction
between alternate timelines should be
impossible but the preservation of
information about all three on the SCP
foundation's database has somehow
enabled all three timelines to
communicate with each other through
exchanging intelligence via their own
versions of the database all three
iterations of the foundation across the
three timelines have learned that almost
all of the anomalies they have
encountered since being established are
exclusive to their own timeline there
are a total of 17 anomalies that have
been confirmed to exist across the three
timelines but there is a concerning
factor in all this the presence of an
anachronistic military group referring
to itself as MTF Alp zero this mobile
task Force's direct involvement in the
events of both timeline HC where they
assassinated scp-001 and timeline ow
where they provided schematics for
scp-001-a raises an awful lot of
questions this MTF had to be acting on
orders of the foundation but which
version in which timeline the consensus
among the leading Committees of all
three the high command overseer Council
and OverWatch is that at some unknown
data in the future each of them will
inevitably send their own version of MTF
Alp zero back in time to alter the
foundation's past and in a sense they've
already done it and seen how this
altered the circumstances in order to
inadvertently create the foundation but
this poses the risk of one of these
timelines overriding another thus
meaning all information garnered by
alternate iterations of the foundation
could be lost so putting their heads
together these Foundation leading
committees come to the conclusion that
they need to attempt to merge all three
timelines and it seems the way to do so
is using the device that timeline OC's
founder wanted to build and that
timeline ow's founder was able to
construct this device is how this
proposal for scp-001 was given its
nickname the Noir box the intention of
the Noir box is to shunt all three
timelines into a stable joint path like
turning loose strands into a single
length of twine as such the leading
Committees of all three different
timelines have agreed to share their
Intel on how each of them can safely
create their own Noir boxes and all
three will be used to merge the
timelines every member of high command
the overseer Council and OverWatch sign
off on it but whether or not the plan
works is another matter the fabric of
time is delicate and one wrong move
could tear everything apart now check
out scp-001 Noir box proposal hated
Caesar and scp-001 Overlord censure for
more